good morning everybody Welcome to day
three of the boot camp so exciting hope
everyone is feeling thoroughly exercised
um yeah so today we are happy to again
have prad Hara from the Tata Institute
of fundamental research um uh again
still unfortunately remotely hopefully
you'll be able to join us soon in person
um and like prad's last talk this talk
will also sort of go give a deeper dive
into something we've already heard an
overview of so uh we've heard about
locality from Elena and we also heard
about uh sort of quantum PC codes which
are related to um C3 LTC constructions
and uh prad will sort of go deeper into
that so thanks so much for again staying
up late prad and take it
away thanks Mar good morning everybody
good evening from Bombay so as Mary said
this will be a talk on recent advances
and locally testable codes you possibly
heard uh Talks by Elina on locality in
coding Theory and also Talks by niik on
Quantum ldpc codes so this will be on
some recent very recent recent results
so about a year and a half ago so two
sets of authors the theur Evra Le lotki
Moses and pant and kachev that have
independently surprised us with this
wonderful result which they had proved
one they basically showed the following
that is for every art for every rate R
between 0 and 1 there exists some
distance Delta also between 0 and 1 and
a query complexity q a constant Q such
that there is an explicit construction
of error correcting code CN with rate R
distance Delta and which is locally
testable with just Q
queries so it's solved a long-standing
open problem in the world of coding
Theory basically are showing that c Cube
LTC C do exist C Cube stands for C the
three C's being constant query constant
fractional distance and constant
rate so what I'm going to be doing in
this talk is basically trying to give
you a highlevel overview of this amazing
result proved by these set of
authors
uhra L lotki and Moses independently by
pantel and kachev must mention that
pantel and cach in addition to proving
this they also approved what our Quantum
ldpc caches and you you have heard talks
on this
result
yesterday so what's going to be the plan
of my talk the talk outline is more or
less going to go as follows we'll do a
quick recap you would have seen locally
testable codes but let's do a quick
recap of locally testable codes we'll
see some of the common studied locally
testable codes namely the Hadad code
read M code huh and then we'll go on to
look at various attempts
given these codes what attempts to try
to make construct CQ
LTC see why these attempts fail and then
eventually go to the DM construction so
they as I mentioned there have been two
sets of authors who proved the same
result the construction is more or less
identical the slight differences between
the two I had more or less a ringside
view to the work of dinur at all I've
been working with several of these
authors for a while so I have a much
closer view point of the DM construction
so what I will do in this talk is focus
on the DM result and I'll be happy to
talk
about not today but some other time the
differences and similarities between
these two constructions so what we'll do
is a DM Construction in particular we'll
talk about the underlying structure
behind the construction what's the code
on the that's built on the structure and
finally I'll give sort of a bird's view
of the proof Pro of
testability so that's going to be and
once again as before please stop me
answer ask any questions or so I have a
certain number of slides but it's not
necessary that I complete all of them
would just want to give a flavor of what
goes into these in the construction in
the construction of these locally
testable codes okay so let's get started
so just quick uh this one a recap of
what are locally testable codes even
before what are codes a code we'll in
general be interested only in linear
error correcting codes codes which are
linear it's just a a vector space for us
it's just a vector space of 01 to the N
for the entire purpose of the stock
we'll restrict our attention to codes
over the binary alphabet just 0o and one
so we're looking at some linear error
correcting code which is just a vector
space over over the field gf2 n and n
dimensional Vector space n is referred
to as the block length of the code there
will be two parameters of interest to us
two of
parameters one which is of interest in
general when you talk about any code
this is what is called the rate of the
code which is basically the dimension
for a linear code it's the dimension of
C Over N over the block length that's
basically how much information is
carried per bit of the code word and
then distance which is the minimum
weight of a non-zero code word in the
code and such objects are extremely
interesting to us we would like to
construct code which are constant rate
constant distance we do by now know
several such constructions and it's
still open in the Fe field of error
correcting quotes what's the best rate
versus distance trade-off one can get
there are these random constructions we
get and we come very close to explicit
construction achieving them but we don't
know if we can do any better and there's
a big wide open problem this getting the
right best trade-off between rate and
distance what we'll be interested is not
the tradeoff we want to add yet another
parameter yet another qualitative
parameter to the code namely the notion
of testability what is testability so
we'll say a code is locally testable
with Q queries if there's a tester that
has query access to given a given word
tosses a few points reads some Q bits of
the word and then decides to accept or
reject so it looks it looks at the code
very very locally and based on this
local View it decides to accept or
reject the code and it should have these
following completeness and soundness
properties if the string is in the
language if the given word is actually a
valid code word then it should accept
with probability one if it's not in the
code word it should at least reject with
some probability which is proportional
to the distance of the word from the
code okay so you would have seen this
this one and what's the parameter of
interest to us how many bits do you have
to probe in order order to do get this
so this quantity Q the number of bits
you need to probe is called the locality
of the tester and what we are interested
is to construct codes with constant rate
rate which is a constant between zero
and one distance which is a constant
between 0o and one and locality which is
also a fixed Universal constant say five
10 or some fixed constant we want to
construct locally testable codes with
this
feature so why are
sorry second why are such codes
interesting and useful so just for some
alen would have mentioned this but just
let's quickly go over why why did why
did several of us coding theorists and
theoretical computer scientists get
interested in locally testable Goods the
primary motivation come came from the
work in probabilistically checkable
proofs P pcps were sort of implicit in
almost every single PCP construction
starting from the early 90s more or less
the first locally testable code which we
know is the testability of the Hadad
code in the early works of Blum Luby and
rubenfeld and the seminal works of Blum
Luby rubenfeld they then moved on to
even further other locally tested codes
namely the ones based on the readed
Muller code or the low degree tests
rubenfeld s Sudan Fidel Sudan studied
various of these and these sort of
formed the backbone of the PCP theorem
the PC each time you had a better
locally testable code construction we
had a better PCP theorem that's all in
fact the Improvement in the PCP theorem
in the early 90s each of them was
accompanied by a corresponding
Improvement in a locally testable code
Construction in fact Spielman in his
remarkable thesis did construct one such
locally testable code he used it and he
showed that you can check in fact this
is line from this one you it's also he
mentioned it's not just sort of a
theoretical interest it's useful in
practice can check on the fly if many
errors occur and so can request
retransmission and he sort of suggested
that this possibly locally testable
codes of such codes exist this will be
very useful in
practice and the one but though locally
trable codes were sort of implicit in
the PCP literature for more than a
decade they were actually formally and
systematically the study was initiated
by gold and Sudan who then asked what is
the highest Poss rate of LTC so we PCP
is typically constructed codes which
have constant queries and in which the
distance is constant but the rate was
typically not constant pcps we still do
not know how to construct pcps which
have just a constant overhead the pcps
are all at least have a logarithmic
blowup and gold and Sudan asked what's
the best rate of A LTC what's the best
rate of a PCP and then what's the best
rate of an LTC because an LTC has always
been the combinatorial backbone behind
uh the PCP
constructions so this is sort of the
motivation why ltc's why several of us
folks in theoretical computer science
and coding Theory got interested into
ltcs I'll now just sort of list out the
various works that we know in this
context what are the various ltcs that
we know so we have the early Works which
showed that the Hadad code is locally
testable with constant queries the read
M code is locally testable with possibly
not L of constant queries but sublinear
number of queries but both these codes
didn't have good rate the rate of adad
code is inverse exponential the rate of
the read M code is depending on which
param setting of parameters it can be at
best inverse polinomial and so these
quotes did not get constant rate at all
and in this quest of trying to get the
best of these three parameters rate
distance and testability I'm going to
list the sort of sequence of works that
are known in this
so it sort of started there some Works
based on coming up with better pcps that
is actually Focus was more on
constructing better pcps not locally
testable codes this started with works
of boson Sudan Wan wigderson and then we
had some work in joint work with Benson
VRE San and VN and B then subsequently
Benson Sudan and dinur finally
achieved locally testable codes with
constant Loc it and distance but inverse
poly logarithmic rate the rate was not
great but the other two were con they
had early works with benon and Sophia
rashod nikova babash Stefan K talked
about cyclic locally testable quotes and
there were several such results which
showed sort of which showed that there
were bottlenecks to existing techniques
to construct these
quods
then the people then took another angle
that is so far the PCP codes we had
constant locality and constant distance
but the rate was one over polog they
said okay let's give up let's try to get
constant rate and constant distance and
let's try to make the locality as small
as possible if not constant what's the
next thing and then there were this line
of Works which sort of initiated with
the works of karti Mayor Roni and saraf
who then said you can apply forget about
the PCP this one if you use expanders
and stuff you can get codes in which
which for constant rate constant
distance but the locality was not
constant it was slightly super constant
it was log n to the Power log
log and you could get such sort of
codes then a more systematic study was
initiated by Koffman and Sudan who asked
what properties actually make certain
codes testable and they start of studied
this notion of aine invariance which
initiated a very interesting sequence of
works of and Sudan talked about this and
more recently in the last five six years
there was this whole angle of using High
dimensional expanders to thought of
construct locally testable ques there a
sequence of works that started from
early in the 70s from the mathematics
Community they were not talking about
locally testable codes but very s
similar objects there's been a lot of
work and we're trying to use if High
dimensional expansion can be used to
construct C Cube locally testable quotes
I'll actually come to this point later
I'll say why people thought and I was
one of those people why they thought the
high dimension expansion might actually
come useful to construct locally
testable FS I'll come back to this point
later on in the talk in fact extent
there was enough interest in this that
back in 2019 there was just like this
program at Simons there was a summer
cluster and
Simons devoted to HDX and codes
primarily this particular angle of HDX
is using HDX constructable course this
was before the results of DM and pant
live in kich where people were talking
about what sort of things can come what
can HDX can HDX give you CQ belt sqls I
remember possibly several of you
participants might them yourselves have
been part of this Pro summer cluster
about three and a half years
ago so so let's go into one some of the
existing constructions so what I'll do
in the next 15 minutes or so 15 20
minutes or so we'll go into some of the
standard locally testable codes such as
Hadad code read M code Cod or other code
constructions like expansion codes
expander codes and ask what is it how
can we make it locally testable what are
properties and what and what what's the
extra feature you need we'll try to see
this and we'll try to understand what is
what is a common Fe feature in several
of these proofs of testability and can
we actually abstract this out and
eventually construct a CQ LTC that will
be the goal so we'll sort of spend the
next 15 20 minutes trying to do this and
finally we'll I'm come up to one
particular feature which will then lead
us to the DM
construction feel free stop me at any
point once again okay so let's get start
started on this so so I need a bit of
jargon to go about doing this so firstly
when you're talking about locally
testable codes saying a code can be
checked just with just constant number
of queries this almost by definition all
these codes have to be what's called a
low density parity check code in other
words the code can be described by it
checks which just involve a constant
number of bits the code can be described
as an and of several parities this one
and what is this if people familiar with
this familiar with sort of the notion of
a parity check Matrix for a code given
any linear code there is a parity check
Matrix which is basically the set of all
you just write down all the linear
con sort of set of linear constraint
that span
the all the constraints that the vector
space has to satisfy what we we want is
a list of constraints it's called low
density parity check if there's if
there's a defining set of constraints
basically the rows of the parity check
Matrix in which every row just has a
constant number of ones constant number
of non-zero locations this is the parity
check Matrix of the code equivalently
the code is basically the kernel of this
parity check matrix it's all those words
which who are in the right kernel which
that when H is H multiply H left of the
word w you get the all zeros Vector
that's this is just the parity check
Viewpoint of the this one this is any
linear code has a parity check Matrix
and we'll call it to be an ldpc if it
has a parity check Matrix in which every
row has just a constant number of
uh constant number of uh non-zero
locations in it if that's the case then
you call it a ldpc and almost by
definition a locally testable code with
constant quy complexity has to be an LD
piece so this is the usual parity check
Viewpoint way of writing a code there's
an alternate way in which called the
factor graph in which you sort of write
each row you write these sort of you
write these constraints not in the form
of a matrix not as H * W equal 0 but you
sort of write it as a bipartite graph
which we'll call the factor graph and
this is the most obvious thing doing
doing here going to the left hand side
is going to be the n Bits of the code
these are going to be B basically the n
Bits of the word w W1 W2 W3 W1 and the
right hand side these are going to be
the M constraints each corresponding to
each row we are going to have a
constraint and the edges are going to be
the most natural edges and a constraint
is connected to all
vertices uh which are have ones in the
corresponding locations out here so so
this is just an alternate way of writing
this parity check Matrix this one C is
basically the code the vector space such
that for all vectors for all constraints
on the right hand side if you just sum
up all the neighbors of it the it's all
those words you can put here so that for
every constraint over here if you sum up
the neighbors you get zero model I've
have done nothing so far it's just the
usual parity check representation
written graphically this is a factor
graph of
code and two things that will be of
interest for
us
is we'll talk of two
measures for for for a given word w for
a given word for a given n bit string
one is the distance of the word from the
code how many bits do you have to flip
in order to get make it go to the
closest code word the other one notice
once we have such a um Factor graph
there's a natural local test to it just
pick a random constraint on the right
just query those locations and check if
it is satisfied if it is satisfied
accept else reject and so you can ask
what's the refraction of these rejecting
constraints so given a locally testable
code we can naturally come up with a
factor graph in which you pick a
random what exactly random constraint
exactly uniformly random from the set of
constraints over here and given a factor
graph you can come up with this and the
Hope given a factor graph you can sort
of build a l you can come up with a Lo
local test of course you need to analyze
whether this is a good local test or not
whether it satisfies whether you can
show some properties that relate these
two measures of the code word in
particular what we want is a in a
locally testable code these two meas
measur should be related that is the
distance of the word from the code as
well as the rejection probability that
is a number of constraints that are that
are violated by a given word in
particular we need this condition to be
satisfied if this condition is satisfied
this particular test given by the factor
graph is a good local test for the
underlying
quod question so far I'm just this is
I'm just restating the problem reating
the problem in the language of factor
graphs because it'll be convenient to
for me to later on to describe both the
obstructions and the existing
constructions as well as the DM
construction okay so we're going to view
a code we view a code yeah
specified by the factor graph and
hopefully the right hand side which not
only describes the constraints that
specifies the codeb also we think of it
as a a candidate local test and ask how
good is this a local test for the given
word okay
and what
um why why did we go this Gallagher
actually showed that if you picked a
random such graph a random NM graph
graph in which m is a constant fraction
but significantly smaller than n you
picked such a random graph with constant
rity on both sides then in fact the
underlying code is a good code it has
both constant rate and constant distance
then this uh in fact gag defin the
notion of ldpc code then he show that a
random ldpc code defined by a random
Factor graph in fact is a good code it
has good distance and good
rate this is what Gallagher talked
Tanner sort of ized the notion of ldpc
goods what gager was sort of looking at
what Gallagher said was what the
constraints we'll place at every each of
these con each of these constraint
vertices is check if the parity of all
the neighbors is zero g said Why That's
not necessarily the only constraint you
can check you can actually have some
base code c not defined over dbits the
degree of this and check whether the
local view of each of these vert each of
the vertices on the right in fact is a
member of C not more forly Tanner showed
said let this was the original
definition of ldp equal Tanner said you
could generalize it to this more
extended definition have a base code c
not and then the actual code defined by
this graph is the set of all words such
that for every constraint vertex on the
right if you look at the Restriction of
the word to its the neighbors that local
view should be a member of the code of
the base code c not this is stanner
Construction
and from the early 80s and sipson and
Spielman what they showed was sort of
they considerably strengthened Gaga's
result Galaga had shown a random ldpc
has good rate and good distance SS and
Spielman should if you actually had an
expander if this graph was underlying
graph was an expander then it is then
there are Tanner constructions for which
the underlying code is a good uh code it
has both good rate and good distance and
we had explicit expander construction so
this gave rice to a family of explicit
code
constructions constructions so let's go
into this a little more closely we would
like to ask can these expander code
constructions of sucess fman so they
gave a family of explicit code
construction which had both both
constant rate constant distance what I
would now like to ask is can this be
enriched to also have constant local
testability and if not what are the
obstructions along the
way so let's have a closer look at these
expander codes an equivalent way of
defining these expander codes which will
come useful to us so far we defined
expanders as a bipart at graph I didn't
Define expander formally but we can what
whichever definition of expanders you
work with this the under if that's a
good expander and there's a suitable
Tanner Bas base code c not the
underlying SS of Spelman show that the
online graph will be a good uh
code what I want now to show is you will
let's move from the bipartite case to in
which you have just a regular graph
which is a a dular expander graph it has
a spectral expansion Lambda the second
ion value is Lambda which is bounded
away from
one you can and suppose you have a base
code c not on these d c not this graph
was D regular you can come up with a
code on the edges of this graph in the
following sense so you define a new code
so the the ingradients are these two
objects one is an expander graph a dular
expander graph with some whose second
ion value is bounded away from one and a
base code c not on dbits and assume the
base code has good distance it's only on
dbits therefore you can search you can
do a Brute Force search and lay your
hands on the best uh code c not you can
put these together to get a code which
is going to reside on the edges of this
graph what is the code it's it's all
words
F on on the edges this is said to be a
code word if for every vertex if you
look at the
neighborhood if you look at the
neighborhood of any vertex what you see
locally over here should be a member of
C not this is just an alternate
description of what I had in the
previous
slide and C Felman instructor showed
that if you have a good expander of this
type and you had a good base code c not
then this code that you constructed H
notice this this is explicit family of
expanders with growing size larger and
larger n this is just a base code a
fixed code of dbits if you put these two
together what they showed is you get a
growing family of codes on the edges of
this graph and it inherits both the rate
you can show that it it inherits rate
and distance from the base Cod if the
underlying graph were a good
expander more formally they showed that
if you had these two that if you had a d
regular Lambda expand a graph G on N
vertices and a base code c not with rate
R not distance Delta KN
then you can show that the underlying
code will
have reasonable rate in fact the
dimension of the code will be at least
size of e * 2 or not minus one this is
just Dimension counting you just count
the number of bits minus the number of
constraints and hence you can show that
if the base code rate is at least a half
then the expander code that you conr
here will have positive rate so in
particular it has a constant rate and
they also you can use the expander
mixing LMA to show the the distance of
this code is at least Delta KN into
Delta KN minus Lambda this is a
straightforward application of the
expander mixing LM so this is basically
sub SP result they said take an expander
graph with good expansion with second
value Lambda then take a base code c not
this is a explicit code on a small on
just on dbits which has rate R KN and
distance Delta KN you put these two
together you get a code which has rate 2
R minus one and distance this two con
you get two constants out of it by the
way this graph which we can view it so I
I've taken two different viewpoints of
uh codes One is using of expander codes
one is on a regular expander graph other
was on a bipartite graph this graph can
also be viewed on on a bipartite graph
what is it the the code code is sitting
on the edges therefore the bits the
edges you have the right hand side which
is B you draw this graph which is just
the incidence graph between the edges
and the vertices you draw all the edges
on the left side and all the on the
right side you draw all the vertices and
connect them if this Edge is incident on
this vertex and this is exactly the
factor graph which we had talked about
in the previous respon that is for every
local view you're seeing if this vertex
local view that is in particular all the
edges incident on it if the local view
is c not then you accept this is exactly
the factor graph representation of the
expander code of Syer and
Spielman and sier Spielman not only
showed this they showed actually they
gave other they showed that this code
has other magical properties it has
linear time decoding Spielman then
showed that you can further enhance it
to get linear time encoding also what we
are interested is not just these what we
are interested is is this code locally
testable can we come up with the local
test in particular is the most natural
tester for it which is basically choose
a random vertex and check
if the local view is c not is this a
good tester for is this a good tester
for this code that's what we care
about any questions so
far okay so this was expander codes so
now let's what we show you can ask we
had this nice beautiful construction of
substance buman question is does this
construction extend to local testability
can I pick up and
so how did the work go if this graph
were an expander Sy Felman showed that
the the code that you construct out of
it is a good code it has good constant
rate constant distance and then they had
explicit construction of expanders
therefore you get explicit construction
of codes you could ask now same thing
can if this expander had some properties
could you further show it was locally
testable and back then we actually
showed that if you actually picked up
this graph randomly it's going to be a
very good expander what you can in fact
show is it's a good expander therefore
the code will have good rate and good
distance but in fact it's it will
typically for most choices of the graph
the under the given code will not be
locally tested and why is
this it's just because of the fact that
every most almost all these expand codes
will have a word with the following
properties a word Which is far from the
Cod
word sorry this is that's W this F
should have actually been W sorry for
the typo it should have been far
from this word should be far from the
code word and it's rejected by only one
constraint just there's just one vertex
that rejects it that is every local view
passes the test except one local view
there's just one vertex that observes
that the edges the ver edges around it
Viator one
and the proof of
essentially take out to take a take a
random vertex V not and remove that the
underlying graph will still be an
expander graph the new codes are far
from the old code because it's an
expander C it will also have a good
distance therefore it will be far from
the old code all the old code words but
it will violate only one constraint you
can make all of this formul and this was
basically an observation that we had
done lot more than 20 years ago with
Ellie and rash nikova Ellie and Sophia
showing that if you build this graph
randomly then the underlying code is in
fact is not testable forget about
testable with constant peries it's not
even testable with a linear Frac number
of
queries so so this shows that if the
underline graphs are expanders which was
a very nice way to construct codes the
codes that we cons the codes that we get
here are most likely not going to be
locally testable but on the other hand
we have these graphs such as we have
these codes such as the Hadad code the
read merer code which were which are
extremely well testable they're not
constant uh they don't get good one of
the properties is not good but they
testable codes so how do you reconcile
this that they Al is there an underlying
Factor graph is isn't there an
underlying expander under these graphs
why does this sort of counter example of
with El and Sofia not work even in
the Hadad and readed Mal so let's look
at the proofs of let's look at the proof
of testability of Hadad codes and read M
codes to see where does this actually
break down so we had this whole family
of codes which are testable you want to
understand why does this counter example
that I mentioned in the slide the
previous slide not work for these quotes
these quotes we did results do prove
that they are
tested and for this we have want to view
the H want to write the factor graph for
the Hamming code for the hadat code as
well as the factor graph for the read
meller code what's a natural and in fact
let's write the factor graph which makes
which proves that these codes are
testable so one such Factor graph for
the Hadad code is on the left hand side
write the code word location which are
exactly Hadad code is on 01 to the N
it's a code on 2 to the N this ones on
the right hand side you write all the
tests the tests are basically you choose
three bit
three three nbit numbers of the form X Y
and X Plus y three correlated ones X and
Y are completely independent and the
third one is this these are the
constraints put one for each one of this
this is a factor graph for the Hadad
code and in fact the proof the blam Luby
rubenfeld proof of testability shows
that this Factor graph actually proves
that the hadat code is testable with
just three three queries the right the
number of the this is three right
regular graph it shows that it's
reable similarly what's happened for the
read meller code if you draw the
corresponding Factor graph for it what's
the read meller code is just evaluation
of low degree polinomial on the entire
space f to the
m so the right hand side is the entire
space f to the m and sorry the left hand
side is the entire space f to the m
these are the Cod word locations Cod
word bits and what is the right hand
side an alternate description of a read
M code is the fact that on every line
the Restriction of the code is a read
Solomon code word so read M code word
for certain choice of you can say this
that for when you restricted a low
Dimension Subspace say a line the
Restriction of the read Muller code is
actually a read Solomon code so for
every vertex here for every line here
you have all the aine lines in the space
f to the m and it's connected to all the
points that are lie on this line and the
local cons code word c not is basically
the read Solomon code word and proofs of
low degree test basically say that this
Factor graph is a good local test for
the read meller
code now why so how do you reconcile
that there exist these codes for which
factor grph why doesn't this
old counter example with not work over
here why do these why do the Hadad code
and the factor gr have it you recall how
did the proof of non- testability go we
dropped off one of the constraints and
asked the new this one now you could
drop a constraint only if dropping it
changes the code if if you drop a
constraint and the code does not get
changed then dropping the code does not
change the property this is basically
asking if if you go back to the parity
check Viewpoint typically we work with
the rows which are just linearly
independent but you could in principle
add lots more constraints to it which is
forms you don't have to work with the B
the par check doesn't have to the rows
of it doesn't don't have to be a basis
for the Dual code they could just be any
spanning set you could add more of them
and both in both the Hadad Factor graph
and the read M Factor graph the right
hand side actually has far more code
words than just a basis it's it's a it's
a much much richer spanning
set in fact there are heavy dependencies
between these
graphs so what I want to say is these
codes so there's the bits that are the
constraints that we have and then there
are lots of dependencies these
constraints are not just they are not
they are not linearly independent the
factor graph constraints not linearly
independent there's heavy dependencies
between them and in fact if you stare at
the proofs of both Hadad testability and
Reda testability the underlying
construction had this three- layered
feature for it for example the
Hadad proof If you people recall the
common tutorial Blum Luby rubenfeld
proof of this one it had the underlying
proof had this part there was the bits
there's of course the these are the
constraints which is the triples X Y X+
Y and then there's this notion which
Madu and others call Magic Square in the
construction while trying to prove
testability of it there was this object
I'm not going to Define what the object
is there was this three- layered object
and the magic square will basically tell
you that all the constraints which are
dependent on this together are sort of
dependent constraints these are not
independent constraints that is if this
is a this is Neighbors to some eight
such constraints it says those eight
constraints there's a linear dependency
between those eight constants they don't
form a completely independent this one
so underlying the proof of testability
of the hadat code was this sort of a
three- layered structure which was the
Cod word bits the triples and the magic
squares and almost exactly the same
thing happened even for the read merer
code you had the code word bits you had
aine lines and these aine lines were not
linearly independent the constraints
defined by the aine lines were not
linearly independent if you look at
lines which are sitting in a plane they
had dependencies among them so if you
looked at this complex which is the in
fact the aine Gras manian complex there
is a dependency out there and this
dependency was used effectively in the
proof of testability of read M goodes so
one could ask all these proofs the
proofs of tability of Hadad codes read M
codes had this
underlying underlying three- layered so
if you had good three- layered
structures can we build ltcs from these
three layered structures so where do we
lay our hands how do we lay our hands on
such three layer structures which are
good Goods we already needed that the if
the first two layers form an expander
graph then it's a good code so we need
these two layers to be an expander code
and we want something more of the third
layer which will let you have the two
expansion from the first two to
guarantee constant rate constant
distance and then the third layer
somehow to guarantee your local
testability so why so then started this
quest for what are these three- layered
objects what are the potential three
layered objects that we could use in
order to construct locally testable cods
and the first such thing came from this
is where High dimensional expander sort
of entered the picture High damed
expanders are a natural generalization
of expanders to multi-layered expanders
I view them as two-layered objects and
these are a natural extansion to
multi-layered objects and ask suppose we
had a high dimension expander with
suitable properties can we use these
objects to actually construct locally
testable
fods and the sort of idea was sort of
floating for quite a while in fact it
was think starting from the early works
of Kaufman and lotki
and sort of use something local high
dimens expandion local to feature use
something locally and then use expansion
to globalize this one there have been a
sequence of Works trying to go along
these lines some related to locally
testable quotes but in general this
taking this feature of going from local
to Global in
particular right during the Simon
cluster from 2019 in joint work with
yamit and NOA we showed that if the HDX
satisfies certain properties and there's
a base code that has that speaks well
with the H HDX and it's an LTC then when
you lift it using this Factor graph the
corresponding lifted code will be a good
LTC so we had this sort of abstract
construction you give me an HDX with
some properties and a base code with
some other properties that speaks well
with the HDX and you lift it you will
get a LTC unfortunately what following
our work cman and openm also had a
similar schema to construct Goods
unfortunately the problem is we did not
know how to instantiate this we did not
have we had HDX but for those HDX we
didn't have good base codes that spoke
well with it and if it had good base
codes we did not know what's a good HDX
that will work with we did not know how
to instantiate this abstract schema to
construct this once and this is where we
this was where I was for a while
till the erra Liv lot Moses sort of
surprised us and showed us that
actually we were hit X are not required
for this a slightly Beaker object called
Square complexes suffices for this and
that's what we'll do in the remaining 20
minutes or so we'll talk about these
Square complexes which are also these
three- layered objects which suffice to
construct ltcs and they showed a
specific instance that they were able to
give a particular instantiation of this
three- layer structure which they could
come up with an explicit instantiation
and also prove testability of the code
that the three layer structure generated
question questions so far so we now
we'll focus attention to Define what the
square complex is and then we'll Define
what's the code that the square complex
generates and if time permitting I'll
sort of give a high level view of the
proof of
testability
questions okay now let's go ahead so so
what is the expanded quotes we're going
to take so it's going to be the factor
graph is as I mentioned we're going to
have three levels
there's going to be the usual level
which are vertices which are edges and
you're going to have one more level
which we'll call the squares what are
squares we'll Define what the squares
are we're going to have from a given
expander graph we're going to come up
with this three layered graph and and
actual code will reside on the squares
and the edges will form the constraints
and the vertices will form dependencies
on the constraints this is how the code
will be defined this exactly what
happened in the Hadad case in the read M
case we're going to do the similarly
we're going to Define an object which
will have this three layered feature and
it's going to be an expander and we're
going to build some other objects called
squares in it and so the code previously
was residing on the edges of the this
one that's what the EXP sub here it will
not reside on the edges but it will
reside on what I'll Define this object
formally in slide or two on the it'll
reside instead on the squares in this
graph there will be four cycles of size
particular cycles of length four will be
designated squares and actually the code
word the code word will sit on these
squares of the
graph so what is this this one the
example the square complex which the at
all used is what they called the Left
Right K complex so what's the Left Right
py complex so let G be any finite group
and a be any set of generators of G
which is closed undertaking inverses
that is a is in a and a if a is in the
generating set so is a in inverse then
the K graph of GA is basically the graph
whose vertices are the group elements
and the edges are a group connected to
the group multiplied by a now if the if
the gra if the group is not ailan then
it matters whether you're going to pre
multiply it you're going to left
multiply or right multiply so and this
is going to be important to us we're
going to talk about two different types
of multiplication the left
multiplication right multiplication so
with respect to the generator set a we
are going to left multiply and these
will be the edges of the
kaph this will be the K graph
GA we'll work with another so we'll take
two sets of generators one set a and
other set B both of which are closed
under inverses and KRA GA will be these
will be the blue edges in the graph
these will be the edges got by
multiplying by left multiplying by a
generator from the set a and K graph GB
will be the K graph that you obtain by
right multiplying by from a generator
from GB these are the red edges so in
particular from G if you left multiply
by A3 you take get this blue edge if you
WR multiply by B2 you get this red Edge
so you have these graph which has both
blue edges and red edges in the graph
and squares are going to be these
obvious things I'm going to Define it
but squares are basically going to be
this that is take a blue edge a red Edge
a blue edge and a red Edge that comes
back to the original thing such four
Cycles are what we going to be calling
squares eventually this is what I'll
Define it in a second so this is going
to be the squares in our
graph so what are these squares so the
squares are going to be take any take
any element any group element G it has a
blue edge say AG it has a red Edge GB
now both these will this will AG itself
will have a because of the element B it
will have another red Edge going this
way AGB and because of the generator a
there will be this blue edge so given
any group element G and generators A and
B these four edges will exist in the
graph there will be a square of this
type and we call the square the square
square rooted at G we'll call this uh
three tle the square rooted at G notice
the same square could also you could
have started with rooting with ag and
pre multiplying this is the AG with pre
multiplying by a left multiplying by a
inverse and right multiplying by B it
has four roots basically AG GB a inverse
AGB a inverse AGB B inverse a gbb
inverse these are all for you can look
at the Square from four different
viewpoints we'll sort of identify all
these rooted squares as the same square
they're all going to be called the same
square which is this which is basically
take a rooted Square which is basically
a cross g a cross G cross B and then
identify
by this one so these are going to be the
what are we going to call the squares of
the complex and the squares has
naturally has four edges these are the
four edges of the graph it has also four
vertices and these are the set of
squares so set of squares is basically a
cross G cross B quotiented by this
equivalence this is the edges these are
the squares of this graph that's the
Left Right KY complex that we're going
to talk about it has these three levels
it has the squares it has the edges and
the vertices once again formally what is
it g is a finite group you have a are
two sets of generators which are closed
undertaking inverses and the Left Right
K complex is basically the complex whose
vertices are the group elements G the
edges are both the right edges the blue
edges got from the generator a and the
red edges got from the generator B so
it's a union of these two edges you have
both blue and red edges the edges are
lab one of two colors and you have the
third layer which is the squares which
is what I described just now it's
basically a cross G cross V quotiented
with this
equivalence and we'll say that this KY
complex is a good is a Lambda expander
individually just K GA was a Lambda
expander and k k GB was a Lambda
exper and we know how to construct such
objects this will be the objects we're
going we're going to they do exist
explicit families of such bounded degree
Left Right K complexes that are Lambda
expands they just is going to take this
this a fact of the Shelf going to take
this fact of the shelf and construct the
code over
this and I want to say that okay this is
all fine I want to say that this code
this object that we have has lot of
interdependencies and stuff in
particular let's take a particular blue
edge let's take the edge G A this
particular Edge Let's look at what are
all the squares it participates in now
for every element B it participates in a
square Square corresponding to that b so
for example this is the square
corresponding to B3 it participates in
this Square the corresponding to B2 it
participates in this Square
corresponding to B1 it participates in
this Square so sort of every Edge is
sort of like the spine of a book whose
Pages corresponds to so if this Edge is
a blue edge its pages are various
corresponding elements from B it's a
book corresponding to this so it'll be
useful to visualize this sort of this is
called the link of the edge H as a book
whose spine is The Edge e and whose
pages are the squares that contain the
edge e and notice this is not any
ordinary book because every Square every
Square which is every page is not just
contained in one book this particular
square is also contained in a book
corresponding to this being the spine so
in particular you take this as a spine
there's a book containing over there so
rather it's a rather fantastic book
every Square in a page is in four
different books corresponding to the
four different edges of the square so
sort of a fancyful imagination going on
out here this is from the Viewpoint of
the edges let's look at it from the
Viewpoint of the vertex so for every
vertex a uh G it has mod a and mod b
neighbors these are all the a blue
neighbors and these are all the red
neighbors and let's draw all the squares
that touch this particular G notice that
this is in one to one correspondence
with a cross B the set of squares
because for every pair a you will have a
square so given a g there is this
whole there's this whole tensor product
like structure there this there's this A
cross B which is looking as the all all
the squares that contain G are are in a
one to one bijection with a cross B I'm
going to sort of stretch this
imagination sort of say that these are
sort of you have these fantastic books
in which every spine is contained in
four different books and I'm going to
view these as sort of book bookshelves
in
which the bookshelf has a books on its
row column and B books on its rows with
the Restriction that the eighth book in
the column shares a common page with the
be book in the row so it is sort of the
book these bookshelves are sort of
heavily intersecting and you can
continue this analogy and you say that
the square complexes sort of intersect
each other and eventually you're going
to get this structure which is what the
actually this was one graphic designer
at Simons who designed this picture when
er first gave this talk talking about
how this structure possibly looks like
it's various Pages this one sort of
looks like a library complex in say hog
in in Harry Potter in the Hogwart
Library complex or something it looks
there are these fantastic books with
having all sorts of
dependencies
sorry yeah so the square complex is like
a library complex with mired
intersection and it is these
intersections that are going to give us
this redundancies in this edifice over
which the code is going to be
constructed so that's the Left Right KY
complex I defined what the complex is we
now need to Define what the code is in
other words I need to Define in this
edifice what are the legal code words
that can be written on this H so what
are the legal words that can be
transcribed on the pages of this book
more precisely because the pages are
actually the squares of this complex
so what we'll do for that is we'll take
two base codes CA which is a base code
of Just length size of a so it's a
constant size code just like in the case
of sub of Spelman case we had a base
code c not which was only a constant
size one we'll take a base code CA and
another C base code CB and the only
restriction is going to be that you're
now going to put bits on all the every
page is going to be you're going to
write a bit on every Square such that if
you look at an a
book if you look at an a book what you
see on the pages should be a code word
from the element from the uh code book
CB if you look at so in particular if
you go to this
picture this is what I call a book A
book who because its spine is a blue
edge and a edge what are what are the
legal words that I can write here if I
look at all the bits AC on written on
the different squares of this thing it
should be actually corresponding from
the B Cod the code word the code book CB
similarly any if you look at a red Edge
if you look at all the blue pages that
in the Blue Book containing it it should
be elements from CA that's the
Restriction that's the Restriction which
we have so the code word bits are placed
on squares each Edge requires that the
bits on the squares around it are in the
base code depending on whether it's a
blue edge or a red Edge if it's a blue
edge then what should be written there
is code code from CB if it's a red Edge
is other code and that's the that's the
entire code that's the code the code is
all words that can be written on the
squares so that for all AGB if you look
at for for all AGB if you look at what's
written on a particular red Edge what
you see is actually a blue code book
word from CA and similarly the other so
that's the entire code that's the code
and what we want to show is this for
certain choices of CA CB and the
underlying K complex this is is actually
locally
testable it's not hard to show that the
rate of this code is 4 R minus 3 so in
particular if R was larger than um 3
over 4 the this is going to have
positive rate this is a simple
calculation just Dimension counting even
distance of this code is easy to do it's
a simple consequence of expander mixing
Lama you can show it all that is needed
is to show is local testability what we
would like to show is this code is
locally
testable
and what's key observation over there
what they showed is now what did we
notice that we had this we call this
Viewpoint of we use the code to define
the code we use the blue books and the
red books but we also said that there's
this other object over here the link of
a Vertex looked like a cross B so in
particular what we want to I'm going to
use that fact to define the local views
of a Vertex look are like tensor quotes
they are actually a member of CA tensor
CB if it's a valid code word it should
be a member of CA tensor CB because this
is a group element G will see A cross B
the number of squares it will
participate is a cross B which is
exactly such a object and what it will
see written in those squares will be a
valid element of CA tensor CB if it is a
valid code word and what we'll assume is
if this tensor code actually has some
properties which we'll call robustly
testable let's not going to the
definition of this right now if it the
tensor code has some properties it's
testable with some parameter row and
this parameter row is and the expansion
of the graph was significantly smaller
compared to the rugor then the at all
showed that the code that we constructed
is actually locally tested and it's it
has a very natural tester also the
tester is just the following tester it
just picks a Vertex G uniformly at
random looks at all the mod a * mod b
squar is touching G namely it's going to
look at this entire thing and then
accept if this belongs to the tensor
product code if it is it's going to
accept otherwise it's going to reject
theod that's the tester it's a very
natural tester and it's in fact the
tester that comes
from the three- layered Factor graph you
can look at it this is exactly the
tester you get and what they prove is
this code is
testable if the underlying tensor
product code is robustly testable Mary
how many minutes do I have can I have
about five six minutes more and I'll
just yeah
okay is the code construction clear and
the theorem statement clear only thing
which I haven't defined over here is
this notion of robustly testable of the
tensor product quote notice that this is
a property of just the base quote it's
not a property it's property of just CA
tensor CB it's not a property of this
growing family of code it's a property
of some constant sized object which we
can ask that's if such a property is
true then F and what is the
property the property is the following
this one this is a property defined by
Ellie basan and Mudan close to 20 years
ago and they showed that a they said
that a code the tensor product code is
robustly testable if you look at the
this for any word any possible word on
this square if the distance of the word
from the tensor product is
always constant times the row distance
plus the column distance what is the row
distance row distance is take the
average distance of each row to the code
CA and column distance take the average
distance of each column to this one if
you take those two averages that
distance is one this is stating that the
natural testure for the tensor product
code which is what you given a word here
pick a random row and a random pick
either a random row or a random column
and check if it is a member of CA or CB
if this is a good test for the tensor
product code then you say that CA tensor
CB is robustly tested
this is basically saying that the tensor
product code is testable by the natural
tester which is just pick a random row
or a random column check if that's a
good if that's a good tester then you
have it and fact the early works of
penson Sudan followed by works of theur
Sudan vdas
and subsequently improved by boson show
that if the underlying code has certain
properties then it's in fact robustly
testable and some such codes are for
example random ldp PC codes ltcs this
one notice these are only properties on
constant size objects so you can
actually Brute Force search find a code
which has this property once you have
this property you instantiate it on the
larger object and it you get a family of
codes which are locally tested this is
what the dinor at all proved over
here what's the proof of local
testability I'll skip this for want of
time it's not a hard proof once you set
the machinery for it one it's not a hard
this one I'll skip this want of
time what we go on is finally how do
conr you instantiate the whole object
with an explicit family of K
graphs and so basically you take if ex
family of K graphs you then choose base
codes which have rate greater than 34 so
choose any base code with this the
search you can do a root Force search to
find such a good to choose a expand a
family Lambda is considerably smaller
than Delta and row
and then if you construct this
underlying object this will be locally
tested by the theor at all construction
by the theorem which we have
proven that's the construction we didn't
have time to skip the proof for want of
time but that's basically the constru
construction is fairly simple it
observes that what we need is this three
layered structure it builds this three
layered structure which are the squares
the edges the vertices these have the
sort of three dependencies it has both
the factor graph in it and the
dependencies in the constraints will
such an object and shows that this
object is actually locally
testable okay just wrap up with a quick
sort of open questions so one thing is
in the back in the early days every all
LTC constructions were accompanied
actually followed a PCP construction
these are the few LTC constructions
which don't have corresponding PCP
construction we could ask if there
exists corresponding pcps and this would
be great because that would say that
there are pcps with constant rate this
is something that's open and if such
pcps existed it would be remarkable for
various both theoretical and practical
applications you can ask such codes are
they actually practical codes and then
we could ask if you can actually
instantiate the HDX approach if you can
actually make it work Are there specific
HDX that you can construct Cod what we
showed were Square complexes you could
ask for larger complexes cubical
complexes take larger Dimensions whether
some such thing would help all of these
are open right now and by the way this
construction is completely motivated by
ltcs the construction of pantel and cach
also looks very similar if you look at
their paper the pictures over there are
very much similar to the pictures that
the all had over here complete with this
references for this is of course the
dinor at all paper also had written a
blog post on this in the Simon's web
page Which con consist basically of the
entire description I gave just know
these are good references for based on
which I the talk I will stop with this
thanks and I should thank these slides
are due to E I modified them for the
purpose of this
lecture
question can't call on people H
sure a nice talk I'm curious so I guess
uh the the resulting sort of um query
complexity is like the you know the
product of the two generating sets that
you get but if you care about like a
really small constant you know say I fix
the constant ahead of time um is there
anything that you can do with these
sorts of arguments or is it sort of you
need the constant to be large enough
depending kind of on that Lambda I guess
there is some sort of I mean it's it's a
constant but you can't I can't choose
any constant as small as I like probably
right I don't don't know how to so you
can get it to be these constant you can
make them small constants like 10 or 12
no no no you can't make them it's
something depending on Lambda it's
something depending on Lambda so it's
not it's a fixed constant I don't know
how to you are asking if I can make it
three or this one there are just just
sort of what how does it depend say on
Lambda and these sorts of things as well
I guess are there some sorts of
tradeoffs there that you need at the
moment so there are some generic ways in
which if you give me a dltc I can
construct it to a q a smaller LTC I not
I don't so I don't know which direction
these off the top of my head there are
some results which go this way that you
can do these so they might you might but
there's a severe loss in parameters and
what I'm don't recall at the top of my
mind is what is the which parameter does
it hit while doing
so but the the query complexity is not
really that not really that large it's
basically you want a tensor product code
with say you could get tensor product
quotes with 10 x 10 or something which
have this property and instantiate this
you would get it
yeah I guess sort of a clarification
question so you you like kind of
motivated this three layer graph way
viewing things via the like Reed Muller
and Admar testing is it
right is it right to observe that like a
distinction or one of many distinctions
I guess but one distinction here is that
in those cases your checks are still on
like the edges like the middle layer
while here your checks are on the
vertices and whether that's a like a key
difference in these
constructions no so the checks the
checks are still it was a three- layer
structure the three layered structure
just said that these are the code word
bits the F the left most layer was the
code word bits the middle layer were the
constraints and the rightmost layer was
the sort of the Redundant the it talks
about the dependency in the constraints
and here also you have exactly the same
thing the left most layer is the squares
where the bits are sitting on the middle
layer are the edges and each Edge is
putting these constraints stating that
if you look at it from this Edge uh what
you should see are code words from CA or
CB depending on whether it's a blue edge
or red Edge and then for on the right
hand the rightmost layer is a vertices
which tells you basically there are
because it's a tensor product code there
are dependencies between these
constraints so it's in it's exactly the
same picture it's just that we drew it
as now the representation M from the
code word bits the code did not sit on
the edges but sat on the squares but
that's just already when we went to read
Mueller there were no edges and vertices
it was this this three- layered
structure on which it was doing and it's
the same three layered structure that
we're talking about here I guess in this
case the like the the local checks that
you're making themselves are on the
third layer while in the p more case the
checks you're making are like the the
two boys right which were on the second
layer so so yeah what you say is true so
the way I stated the test was as
if the way I stated the test was take a
vertex and do it but you could have also
done the test because the tensor product
code is testable you could have just
taken an edge and just check the page
the squares that participate in that
edge and check if it's a member of CA or
CB that will also be a good
test because the 10 of product code is
testable so then it will exactly fall in
the spirit of the three layered graph I
talked
about so does that mean you could have a
constant that's just size V or size for
yes this proof basically this proof
tells you it's just had I gone into I if
I knew I was not going into the proof I
would have that would be the test I
would have described it's just easier to
describe the proof working with this
tester rather than than that test
still so yes the query complexity can be
further reduced to Min of to Max of size
of a size of B because you could
actually you don't have to query the
entire tensor product code you can just
query a random row or a random column
and just check that that's suff because
we know that the tensor product code is
robustly testable that's a assumption we
are doing so instead of checking that
the tensor this a valid member of legal
member of the tensor product code it's
sufficient to check a random row or a
random column yeah so the query
complexity is actually not a times B but
actually Max of a comma
B uh so the current best construction
does it take exponential time respect to
the degree because of the
search Oh you mean to say with respect
to the
degree right
actually so you can use these sort of
the question is how do I construct these
random ldpc codes LTC
codes yeah because it's for such
constant things I don't know what's the
best way the only way I know is Brut sir
so there might be a more systematic way
of coming up with these robustly
testable V on this small alphabet here I
don't know on top of my
head uh well let's uh let's thank out
again
uh 25 minute break and come back at
11:05 thank
you